Yeah, probably!
It's not close!
Hey, let's go!
That's crazy.
Did you just hear powers?
He was bragging, he's like, dude, I probably...
He's like, dude,
I probably have more beers than all these kids can buy.
No, like...
Yeah, probably.
That was like, individually.
Yeah, individually.
I know.
Me too, all of us.
Yeah, get off!
Get off!
I don't know.
Yeah.
Honestly, yeah.
Do you want an award or something?
What was the point of saying that?
No, I was just like, putting it in perspective.
They'll say it, and it's like...
Yeah, no, you're right.
I see where you're coming from.
They probably never thought that.
Another...
Oh, move it, move it, move it!
We need help over here!
Whatever, sir.
Did the ref change?
I'm pretty sure he did.
Don't yell at me.
No.